[Music]
on China's Southeastern Coastline facing
Taiwan is the huan military Air Base
since 2020 the airbase has been
significantly
upgraded with new hardened shelters an
extended
Runway and a new apron for jet
fighters Haan is just one of at least a
dozen Chinese airbases in southern China
that have seen infrastructure upgrades
in recent
years defense analysts say these change
are part of China's preparations for
conflict over Taiwan the self-governing
island that Beijing claims and has
pledged to take by force if
necessary here's how China has been
upgrading its air bases to strengthen
its military
capabilities and what challenges that
poses for Taiwan and its allies in the
event of a
conflict The Wall Street Journal asked
security analysts to study satellite
imagery of of over a dozen air bases
within 500 mil of Taiwan Alex Neil is a
former Defense analyst for the British
government and specializes in
asia-pacific security the modernization
uh and the upgrades of these air bases
um has has been specifically focused on
the ability to move air assets to these
airfields which are close to the theater
of of battle in its biannual defense
report Taiwan warned China's recent
construction at airfields along the
coastline is designed to seize air
superiority in the event of War across
the Taiwan
Strait China's Air Force has been
expanding its bases to accommodate a
wide range of military aircraft ready
for different types of
combats these upgrades can be seen in
the long Tian Airfield one of China's
closest bases to Taiwan long Tian
Airfield is quite a special example of
the pla's modernization because it not
only has an array of helicopters and
fighter jets at one end of the Airfield
you can make out camouflaged hardened
shelters which are housing uavs so large
drones which can be in the air
reconnoitering the battle space China
has developed supersonic drones such as
the wz8 capable of penetrating deep
Behind Enemy radar systems a leaked
paper from the Pentagon suggests the wz8
Drone is based here at the Luan airbase
and satellite imagery shows significant
upgrades have taken place in recent
years the leaked papers suggest the
upgraded basis on China's southern coast
would operate as potential Landing
fields for the Drone during
reconnaissance missions over
Taiwan China has been working on the
so-called survivability of its air
Assets in the face of a retaliatory
strike by hardening the bunkers where
aircraft are stored with layers of
reinforced concrete and steel if we look
at a closeup of this Airfield here you
can see hardened shelters in in this
area so aircraft on the apron would be
able to advance quite quickly into these
hardened shelters
to refuel them to arm them the purpose
of hardening shelters is to ensure
aircraft can survive direct strikes on
an Airbase allowing jet fighters to keep
flying once a conflict has started if
there were an immediate threat to the
Airfield itself through missiles
launched at sea or indeed Taiwanese or
US aircraft it would be to able to
withstand a preemptive strike or to have
a second strike
capability a number of the air bases
like aning also have runways with direct
access to Mountain bunkers under this
mountain there will be munition storage
facilities as well as fuel and
potentially
accommodation uh for military personnel
uh Sheltering during an attack on the
Airfield the satellite images show work
has been undertaken to harden the
entrances to these bunkers replacing
exposed entran with what appear to be
reinforced structures topped with a
camouflage layer analysts say these
changes are part of China's preparations
to maintain its Air Force in the event
of a
conflict the Chinese military is also
enhancing the survivability of his air
bases by constructing new air defense
units if you look at this you can see
this Cog type configuration which has a
perimeter fence its own accommodation
hardened shed
for the missile batteries and radar
capabilities which would rapidly deploy
onto this Cog to provide air
defense surfac to a defense systems are
designed to protect ground positions
from air attacks these systems are
capable of protecting airfields from
multiple threats including high altitude
bombers so these air defense facilities
are not just for the Airfield but
they're more more broadly speaking a
joined up chain of of air defense
China's Ministry of Defense didn't
respond to a request for comments on the
recent upgrades of its
airbases us officials say China's
military is rapidly cashing up to
Western Air Forces it's clear that
there's been a saturation of this whole
area with air
bases the United States and its allies
are also needing to use their own
geographical reach in order to counter
this
saturation if China were to invade
Taiwan Beijing knows it could spark a
wider conflict in the region there's no
doubt as demonstrated by the hardening
um of these bases that the pla military
leadership is aware that um they will be
big targets for the United States and
and Taiwan forces if there were to be a
cross straight
invasion